hey guys so this video will admittedly
be something completely different today
because i want to introduce you guys to
a new series that i've discovered this
week
and also discuss its latest chapter a
little bit the series i'm talking about
is
kaiju number eight i stumbled across it
when looking for a new series to start
on manga plus
and it's actually listed as the eighth
most popular series there at the moment
even before the likes of chainsaw man or
jujutsu kaisen
and since there are only nine chapters
so far and the cover art looks pretty
damn awesome
i figured i'd give it a go and holy [ __ ]
what a story it is if you want to start
reading before watching this video
all 9 chapters are free to read so far
and the link is in the description below
just make sure to come back afterwards
there are a number of familiar concepts
in here that we already know from other
manga
but so far that really doesn't seem to
be a bad thing at all
just the opposite really the series
written and illustrated by narya
matsumoto
takes place in modern day tokyo the only
difference is that for some
still unknown reason enormous monsters
pop up to harass the people at times
threatening civilization to counter this
the country has created the so-called
defense force
which sole purpose is to destroy these
enormous creatures
the strongest member is mina ashiro a
tough looking woman that we see destroy
one of these gigantrous beasts with
relative ease
up to this point the story carries some
aspects of both attack on titan
as well as pacific rim however kaiju
number 8 addresses an issue that most
giant monster stories gloss over
what happens once these beasts have been
killed
this is where the main character of the
story comes into play
the 32 year old kafka whose name is
drawn from the 20th century author franz
kafka
dreamed of joining the defense force but
has failed to pass the entrance exam
multiple times and has given up on his
dream
kafka was childhood friends with mina
the two made a vow to join the defense
force and protect japan from the kaiju
together
after seeing their own town destroyed
after
failing to follow mina however he has
joined the so-called kaiju cleanup corps
instead
his job as a monster sweeper is to chop
up and dispose of kaiju killed by the
defense force
and so for a change we actually learn
about the nasty side of killing large
creatures in a civilian area
and how to clean up the mess they leave
however
everything once again changes for kafka
when the ambitious 18 year old ichikawa
is assigned to work with kafka
ichikawa also has plans to take the exam
to become a member of the defense force
and with his strong determination
manages to ignite kafka's will once
again
after being attacked by a so-called yoju
smaller monsters that accompany the main
kaiju when they emerge
both kafka and ichikawa stand their
ground but end up in the hospital
there kafka is infected by a small
parasite-like monster
and suddenly his body transforms into a
small but
quite powerful monster himself when
another kaiju appears in the city
he defeats it with ease and is from here
on out known as kaiju number 8
wanted by the public this is of course a
reference to franz kafka's story the
metamorphosis
where the main character one day wakes
up transformed into a giant insect
from here on out kafka learns to control
his new powers at will
and with his newfound strength he and
ichigawa participate in the next
entrance exam
here they meet kikoro shinomiya kikoro
is the daughter of the defense force
commander and her combat power is
far greater than any of the other
applicants she is viewed as the hope for
japan and the future leader of the
defense force
but suffers heavily under her father's
high expectations
during the exam she easily disposes of
the smaller monsters that have been set
as obstacles
similar to the entrance exam in my hero
academia
kikoru defeats most of them including
the main monster in a short amount of
time
however suddenly a mysterious humanoid
kaiju
similar to kafka's own transformation
appears who
revives the monster and gives it a power
up
quickly it defeats kikoru and threatens
to kill her
but in the last moment kafka decides to
reveal his true power in front of her
and takes out the monster with ease in
the latest chapter
we see the aftermath of the fight and
learned that the mysterious monster has
infiltrated the monster sweeper force
by taking up human appearances now
obviously should i decide to keep going
with this series i will make the chapter
reviews much much more thoroughly
however since this is the very first
video on this and most of you probably
have just heard about the story for the
very first time
i prefer to share with you guys why i
have such high hopes for this manga
despite sharing elements with other
popular stories i believe that up to
this point
all of them have been presented in a
quite unique and interesting way
the fact that so little is explained
about the world and how these creatures
came to be in the first place
hint at something larger being at work
here and it feels like this story might
have
quite a bunch of things to be revealed
and explored over time
promising some great world building no
pun
intended in this sense it gives me great
attack on titan vibes as well
but in a more than positive way the art
style is also really nice
reminding me at times of both boku no
hero and
fire force most importantly for me
however the characters
all seem to be more than promising as in
the handful of chapters we've gotten so
far
there's already a lot happening in terms
of characterization
and shaping complex personalities
in addition to the excellent action good
plotting and pacing and quality
character work
matsumoto also delivers some wonderful
comedy
the body team of kafka and ichigawa have
created some excellent chemistry between
the different characters in a super
short amount of time
the story also promises to have a great
balance between some fun shonen vibes
and some
darker and more mature elements which i
personally am a big fan of
many of the panels are flat out
wonderful to look at
all of them are meticulously drawn and
the action is kinetic
and leaps out of the page facial
expressions and emotions are
also wonderfully captured combined with
great writing and a good balance between
inner and outer dialogue
every chapter so far has really captured
me completely
and so overall kaiju number 8 is a
brilliant and fun read
that delivers great chapter after great
chapter
getting me excited for the next one
while it's still way too early to make
any predictions
i think that the story has enormous
potential and i highly recommend
checking it out
you will definitely not be disappointed
and once you've done so please let me
know if this is something you would like
me to cover on a weekly basis
because it really depends on your
feedback and preference
so make sure to share your thoughts on
this with me in the comments below
thanks guys peace
you